[Music]
so
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter laveau
we're used to hearing eu elites
messaging about the importance of values
not everyone in the block agrees in fact
a growing number of conservative
and populist forces are speaking out
against what some
call brussels colonial outlook
conservatives and populists talk the
language of family
and culture eu elites talk of values to
create
a european super state
[Music]
crosstalking the eu in crisis i'm joined
by my guest
onscad in london he's emeritus professor
of international history and former
convener of european studies at london
school of economics
also in london we have donald sassoun he
is emeritus professor of comparative
european history at
queen mary university of london and in
syracuse we crossed
glen morgan he is a professor in the
political science department
at the maxwell school at syracuse
university all right gentlemen crosstalk
rules in effect that means you can jump
anytime you want
and i always appreciate it let me go to
allen first in london um
the um slovenian prime minister recently
condemned the eu's western states
for imposing quote imaginary european
values without respecting
local cultures how do you react to that
because we had a
a letter come out with 16 major figures
uh representing parties all across the
the block very agitated and pushing
back against what they think is brussel
brussels
uh intruding upon their local affairs
how do we react to what the
slovenian prime minister had to say well
it doesn't come as any surprise
because uh there's a great divide in
europe and the european union just now
on matters of
uh culture particularly on gay culture
and various other things
catholic culture the legal protection of
the catholic church in poland or
judicial rights of family rights and
poland
discriminatory legislation hungary
against
gay and lesbian people uh and this is
creating
a cleavage um the letter that you
referred to
is very strange because it
criticizes the european union for being
uh going forward in a federalist path to
which it is actually committed by its
founding treaty
i.e of a closer union it's a
as a criticism by the the the uh
i don't know what's called populist
parties but this is the
anti-bureaucratic
uh parties those who don't want to see
the center expand
but it's never going to get anywhere
it's just a political uh gesture as far
as i could see
okay but it is a political judgment that
speaks to the divisions in europe inside
the eu
okay let me go to donald that's the same
question here i mean
it's interesting what allen had to say
is that it's a lot of
noise um a lot of light not but
not much heat would you agree with that
yes for once i agree with alan that it's
a lot of noise
and also it's um it's as usual
giving the european union more
importance
than it actually has when it comes to
values
there is not very much the eu has
imposed i mean
one can say for instance you can't be a
member of the european union if you have
capital
punishment that is that that sort of
thing
as for european values values
historically speaking are always
constructed in other words people talk
about british values or
french values and they simply have a
list of stuff they think is good
and then they put them in the basket
which says our our values
um but otherwise there's not very much
the the the european union has very
limited powers
for instance it hasn't got any power on
foreign policy it hasn't got any power
on the taxation
it hasn't got any power on
[Music]
welfare so the three most important
powers of the state
are actually totally absent in the
european union
okay well that's very interesting let's
go to syracuse here but
at the same time we have um um
european uh union elites uh threatening
to sanction people in
countries like hungary uh prime minister
urban but his reaction is is that
he's elected on his values on his
platform here
i mean this is an obvious tension right
here because urban will say
we i know you don't like me you know i
know you don't like my politics
but i'm repeatedly being elected because
of my platform
how do you square the circle there go
ahead in syracuse
well the eu is committed to
certain basic values around liberty
democracy and the rule of law
and countries like hungary and poland
knew about that when they signed up
unfortunately over the last few years
orban in particular has uh violated
various dimensions of the rule of law
and the eu has discovered that it is
embarrassingly weak in its ability to
force
and also the polish leadership to live
up to their commitments
and now we are seeing a conflict
which i fear the eu will lose
because it lacks the the power
to to force poland and hungary to comply
with their commitments
okay well uh alan what does how's that
forebode for the european union
moving forward because if the polls of
the hungarians can just you know say
we're not going to follow your edicts
uh um should they remain members of it
or should they be
welcomed in the european union because
there'll be other populists and
conservatives will say
well if the hungarians in the polls can
do it why can't we i mean
don't you see the the uh the slippery
slope possibility here
not that i'm particularly against it
either i believe in the democratic
process okay
people elected these officials go ahead
allen
well the trouble is the european union
is a non-elected
bureaucratic institution which
uh is run by you know an assortment of
bureaucrats who have got no democratic
mandate
uh and where the the the people that are
opposing the
the polls the hungarians or whoever do
have a democratic mandate
so it makes life very difficult i mean
the dutch prime minister
said the polls in hungarian should just
quit but
you know there's no way of making these
people quit there's no
mechanism whereby they can be thrown out
and again it's not just them i mean the
germans for example on monetary policy
the german constitutional court is
laying down
markers and saying that if the
european central bank uh persists with
quantitative easing to a large extent uh
the german constitutional court may say
that germany will no longer take part in
any of this
so the the germans are also saying that
for democratic and constitutional
reasons
germany cannot be constitutionally
overridden in economic matters
uh by the european central bank and by
the commission
so uh it's not just the polls and the
hungarians on culture the germans
are also saying on economic matters that
they may not uh
allow the the european sort of banking
system to carry on the way it is
so there are all sorts of um tensions
there but there is no mechanism whereby
the european commission can actually
force
national governments if it's a key issue
into following its lines so um it's not
obvious how things are going to be
patched up
i'm just surprised that many of these
so-called populist parties still want to
work within the european union
i don't see why they don't do what
britain did and come all together
but uh i mean if i i mean i was leader
of uk provides
if this was happening when i was a a
leader of a so-called populist british
party i could never sign
up to because our policy was to come out
all together
well i want to get to the brit i want to
get to the british example in a second
here let me go to donald here i mean in
light of what alan just said there
i mean if the germans don't want to
follow through on monetary policy
uh the polls and the hungarians have
cultural issues i mean is this turning
into the eu
of optionality where you know there's no
downside there's no punishment for it i
mean how is
how do you keep cohesion then if people
can pick and choose go ahead
donald trump but the this is this is the
old
issue some people mainly the euroskeptic
a tribute to the european union
enormous powers they then complain that
these powers are
are there from non-elected people
um but the reality of the thing is that
the vast the that the electorates in
europe
are loyal to their state to their nation
state
they vote for national policies even
when they vote for european parliament
they voted to punish or
give a prize to their own mps to their
own politicians
in other words it is still what the goal
used to say
la hop de patri it is the the
con it is the union of nation states
these nation states have kept
all their powers if they don't want to
be in schengen they're not in schengen
if they don't want a single currency
they don't have a single a single
currency and there's nothing anyone can
do about it
um so the for for many years
including in britain in the last in
well since britain joined the the
uh european union has always been a
terrain of dispute
when in fact there was very little the
european union
could impose on britain okay let's go
let's go to syracuse here i mean
you know one of the the the issues
particularly if we can focus on the
hungarians and the polls is that
they focus a lot on families here and so
you have this kind of odd juxtaposition
where um because of demographics for the
union
uh as a whole they need uh population
growth but then
they would say the hungarians polls for
example say why don't we just be more
friendly to families
and have um uh population growth
organically naturally
within the european union instead of
importing it and so and then the
hungarians and polls and others in
eastern europe say we just don't want
your immigrants
we weren't part of that process of
having people come in so why should they
take them in
for example go ahead in syracuse
well they have to take them in because
if the eu decides that they're going to
have a common
um boundary a common border then
all states have to live up to their
obligations
i would want to say something though in
correction to what alan
said i don't think it's the commission
that runs the eu it is the member states
and also in answer to the question why
don't hungry and poland leave
it's because they get a sizable chunk of
their gdp from eu money
there's no conceivable way they will
leave
hang on hang on hang on finish up go
ahead keep going
that's i mean that's the that's the root
of the matter that hungary and poland
are desperate for eu money and they're
trying to take the money
and not live up to their commitments
okay
alan you want to jump in there real
quick before we go to the break go ahead
alan
uh just one thing there's a tension
between what's being said in syracuse
and what's being said in london
donald is saying that the eu is no
powers whatsoever
it's just a collection of nation states
the company no i wouldn't say it has no
power whatsoever
nobody i said i said it hasn't got
powers on fiscal policy it hasn't got
powers on welfare
gentlemen i'm going to jump in here
we're going to go to a short break and
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion
on the eu in crisis stay with rt
okay let's go back to donald in london
so far in this program we have
two contradictory ideas the eu is just
the all power comes from the member
states
and then juxtaposed to that we have this
all-powerful commission
what is it because that's what the
arguments i hear all of the time it's
not democratic
faceless bureaucrats but then the other
argument is
no all the power comes from the member
states okay
how do you how do you balance that
donald go ahead
well it's obvious that the power comes
from the council of ministers
because it's an agreement between states
the states get together the council of
ministers appoints a commission
and the commission then and the
commission then
um enacts a number of the propositions
which
obtain a majority um
that is the way it has been the idea
that the commission
runs european affairs or interferes in
hungarian culture
is absolute nonsense well i mean the
the the urban and the hungarians are
being threatened with sanctions i don't
know if they'll ever come through with
that
let's go to syracuse here i mean is that
just bluster
okay because i mean i i i was interested
the sanctions would come
from the other states from the other
state okay fine
well i mean all right then then what
when you say
no what is the what is the remedy if if
we've already agreed on this program
that there's really no penalty no
sanction
you want to stay with that donald in
london yes sir um
the the what people say what politicians
say about the european
union is largely determined not by the
european union
but by domestic considerations that is
what is it that will
work well with their electorate the
euroskeptic electorate has increased
enormously
over the last 20 years it has increased
in including in countries
which were enthusiastic about europe
such as italy which now
the largest party is a eurosceptic party
in france marine depend
has maybe nearly fifty percent of the
other votes she's a eurosceptic she
doesn't want to leave now
but you certainly is a eurosceptic so
the increase in euroscepticism
can only increase the number of times
politicians would say it's all the
thought of brussels it's so much better
to say it's all the thought of brussels
than to say it's all my fault well let's
go to syracuse
you're nodding your head in agreement go
ahead explain why
well i think that politicians do tend to
blame
europe for their own failures and
deficiencies when it isn't europe's
fault
mcdonald is right that there are now
euroskeptic parties like
salvini's lager um who do
embrace robust euroskeptic positions
although one wonders
whether when push comes to shove they
will really actually
carry through on efforts to pull out i
mean the lager is heavily dependent on
uh financial capital in the beneteau
region and it is not in their interests
to pull out of the european union and i
suspect that
uh the lager would back down when push
comes to shove well i mean
if i can stay with you i think that's a
very interesting gambit because it's a
good electoral platform
but if you win on it then what do you do
because the
is there really an appetite appetite to
take a brexit move here
and there's not a lot of indications
there alan let me go to you i mean has
the european
union learned anything from brexit
i'm trying desperately to uh to beat
britain into some kind of
postcolonial status it regards britain
not not as a
a sovereign state but is a renegade
province i mean it looks on britain just
now in the
same way that china looks on taiwan
uh it resents bitterly that a state has
left
and it's trying to make life as
difficult as possible for the british
but unfortunately britain is doing very
well without the european union already
and this is resented uh it's trying to
destroy the city of london
uh it's trying to make life as difficult
as possible in northern ireland
and it still has this imperial complex
and it's very very frightened that the
example of britain will spread elsewhere
for example macron was asked if the
french had a referendum how would they
vote and he said they would vote to
leave the european union
but he wasn't giving them a referendum
and i think le pen is now offering a
frexit referendum to the
french should she be elected president
of france
well okay if i go to uh donald how do
you feel
how do you feel about that i mean if the
um if the a chance were given to the
italians or to the french
that they would go that direction and go
the direction of brexit
because there's there's there's there's
a school of thought out there which
because of brexit which i think is
really quite interesting and it's coming
from europe
is that you ban referenda but in a sense
you don't want to hear a democratic vote
i mean
people are interpreting that referendum
in very different ways one is
is uh too much democracy which i find
rather peculiar coming from europe but
other people say it's dangerous because
people don't understand what they're
voting for
donald how do you reply to that well if
the uh italian and the french i think
it's unlikely that they will have a
referendum
on something like brexit because they
might well lose it
in the sense that italy and france might
actually
leave the big mistake david cameron made
is that he had not calculated what the
results might be he thought or rather he
thought
he was going to win and put a stop to
the sniping
from the right wing of his party from
the euroskeptic from those
john major called the bastards um he he
lost
uh he lost the referendum um that is a
lesson
that maybe the italians will it's
interesting that actually
the salvini lega north which is now
called laga
since they've been in this government
this big
large coalition has changed slightly his
tune
over europe because italy got money he
knows that it's not very good at this
stage
to um talk against the european union
so he hasn't said anything against the
european union in the last six months i
mean it may not last
um in other words these politicians are
a bunch of opportunists
who will use whatever is there in order
to get votes there's nothing new here
well calling politicians opportunities
is an
understatement i completely agree with
you there yes i could say something
worse but this is
i could say something worse but i can't
say it on television
let's go back to syracuse here well you
know one of the claims
again these populist um and
conservatives have
um uh with the eu writ large is that
it's
attempting to create a super state how
do you fall down on that because
you know as is explained to me once by a
very prominent eurocrat
is that uh crisis is always an
opportunity for the eu
to ex deepen integration crisis
integration how do you feel about that
go ahead
well i think historically that has been
the case i mean europe has
integrated come together uh through a
process largely of stealth
it was an elite lead process that didn't
involve
the the demos of demoy of europe to a
great
extent i think that process has now come
to an end and i think that
any further integration will have to be
undertaken openly and debated
involving all the people of europe and i
would hope
that they would that they would commit
to building
something like a united states of europe
because i think a
a europe of nation states would likely
return europe to
interwar levels of dysfunction and
economic misery
well that's a very strong statement
there alan how do you feel about that
because
that is the charge that we've you know
and that was all around
the the brexit debate here is that the
the brussels wants too much power
and it is trying to one size fits all i
mean
that was at least the claims that were
made by the brexiteers
okay now i asked you did they learn
anything from it because
there's there we've all agreed on this
program is that euroscepticism is on the
rise
what it exactly means is very unclear to
me because
it seems to me it is more of a a demand
for reform
not to gut the entire project go ahead
alan
well i do understand the letter that's
been signed by the so-called populist
parties
my view is that the more europe
integrates the less efficient
it becomes growth becomes less most of
its major policies have failed the euros
failed
europe stagnated really since the euro
was introduced the italian economies
pretty stood still since the
introduction of the euro
the the more integration europe actually
achieves
the less efficient less democratic less
economically viable the whole thing
becomes and
if it wants to go towards fiscal union
then there'll be a huge uh political
battle
which will divide it up and probably
if it wants to do much about the euro
the situation there will go out of hand
and there might be a bond crisis and you
might end up with the
disappearance of the eurozone i i think
europe is very fragile the european
union is very fragile
i think the divisions are very severe
the ones of our culture
are the ones we've been discussing but
the economic problems are the worst ones
and i think the the euro itself as a
currency is enormously fragile
and if that goes then the whole thing
goes you know donald i mean i talk
we're talking about the fragility of it
all but at the same time one can make
the argument it
it it does have this staying power to
muddle through
i mean again i mean some people will say
you know it's not completely broken
that's why you don't need to completely
fix it but i mean
that's not particularly a um
something that you know you should be
proud of i mean just muddling through i
mean
where is the european project going
right now because
as as we heard earlier more integration
will have to be more transparent
uh there's a there are many people claim
that there is a democracy deficit where
where does
how does it move this project move
forward where people can
um find affinities with it
go ahead donald
well when people talk about a super
state my
reaction is uh to study a bit of history
the creation of states has always been
from the top
a state then imposes on the whole of the
population
a single language there are more than
one languages
an education system a police force
an army and
a bureaucracy and a system of
legislation
and then the italians become italians
the french become french
the british became british and so on and
so forth
so for the european union to become
a super state it would need to be
conquered or something there's i mean
with the exception of yugoslavia there's
only
any example of states which have come
together
by the the accession of
uh different existing states as for
the future i know that um people will
blame the present economic circumstances
on the european union
but the fact is that the global downturn
of 2008
which has been the most serious economic
crisis um
to affect the globe or most of it has
very little to do with the european
union or without europe all right
gentlemen
i'm afraid we've run out of time
fascinating discussion here i want to
many thanks to my guests in london and
in syracuse and thanks to our viewers
for watching us here at rt see you next
time
and remember crosstalk rules